[Music]
tiffany's in georgia we recently
completed
baby step three which means they're out
of debt and have their emergency fund in
place except their home
we'll be meeting with a financial
advisor soon to start on our baby step
four we know nothing about investing and
feel very clueless how can we prepare
ourselves to be a bit more knowledgeable
before our meeting
um i would tell you two things on that
one is prepare yourself by being very
comfortable
with the idea that this is your money
it's your
money
it's your money
there is no reason for you to ever be
embarrassed
ashamed
or afraid
to demand
that you understand what's going on with
your
money
see what's weird is as we go into these
you know we're going to this guy or this
gal's office and they've got on a nice
tie or a nice dress or whatever and
they're they have financial advisors
sitting plaque sitting on their desk and
we don't know nothing
and so we feel all intimidated
almost ashamed that we don't know
anything
but here's the clue it's your money
you're in charge of this money god put
you in charge of this money he didn't
put me in charge of it he put that guy
in charge of it put you in charge of it
it's your money
so i don't want you to go in there with
your head bowed ashamed
like i don't know anything
i want you to go in there going
square shoulder head up chin up it's my
money
and they have to earn
your business
by teaching you something about how to
do something with your money that you
didn't know before
and if they can't teach you and the only
thing they can do is intimidate you then
what you've got is the wrong person
and it's not your problem it's their
problem because you're the customer and
the way they earn your business is by
teaching you
so i wouldn't go in there
humble
i mean you i wouldn't go in there
humiliated humble's okay but humiliated
now i don't know anything you know just
don't um please help me now you can just
go and say listen i don't know anything
about this stuff
but i listen i own this company
ramsey solutions i sit in some of these
technology meetings i got 200 technology
people on our team here
and and they use words i have no idea
what they're talking about
it's like techno cussing or something i
mean i don't know what it is and i go in
these meetings i'm and and and if i'm
supposed to understand what's in the
meeting now sometimes i'm observing the
meeting and i'm not supposed to be in
charge and it's not up to me and i'm
just letting them run in their meeting
i'm not going to interrupt everything
based on my ego but if they're trying to
get me to drop 200 000
into a new server or a new program or a
new whatever
then it is their job to let me know why
i would want to give that much money to
that
and if they can't help me do that then i
don't feel ashamed they should feel
ashamed
because i own the company
and i i don't listen i don't know beans
about technology i know a lot more than
i did two years ago but i i still i
don't
i am no technocrat i have no i i mean i
i'm starting to know what a few of these
things are the
nuances between some of the different
things the basic concepts because i've
had to learn enough about the basic
concepts in order to make the
investments and guess what i got guys
here that can teach me the basic
concepts because they know all the
details same thing you need to know
enough about the basic concepts that you
can make the decision intelligently on
your own
and if they can't help you learn the
basic concepts enough then you've got
the wrong person you should not be
intimidated you don't have to be a bit
more knowledgeable before you go in
there all you have to be is remembering
whose money it is it's your money
not their money
and so kind of strut in there a little
bit i own the place
your job to teach me not my job to be
beholden to you because you've got five
letters after your name
or less
so that you know and do not put money in
something because dave ramsey said too
do not put money in something because
somebody else said to only put money in
investment if you understand it you know
how these people lose their butts on
stuff because they put money in
something they had no idea they trusted
the guy
and his name was bernie madoff
they trusted the guy
and he was not a crook but he was an
enthusiastic ignoramus
which by the way will screw you more
often than actual crooks
people that are enthusiastic ignoramus
has you ever met them they're
enthusiastically stupid
they've they're telling you the exact
wrong thing with great enthusiasm
and you went well they're enthusiastic
and they seem to know what they're doing
and so let's just go with that instead
of you understanding what you need to
put your money into that's how we work
with these pro athletes is how these pro
athletes lose their money it's how these
country music stars and these uh
hollywood starlets lose their money we
work with them all the time when they
hit the wall you know i had 10 million
dollars i don't know where it went well
it's because you gave it to people and
walked off and thought well i hope they
took care of me you're like what do you
need a babysitter when are you going to
be a grown-up
i got me a man one of the guys at nfl
meetings we were in try to go on those
rookie camps and tell those kids the nfl
stands for not for long
average nfl careers of 3.8 years
so i try to explain to him and the guy's
like i got me a mandu you got you a man
what does that mean you got you a man
you bought a man with your signing bonus
how i mean what do you mean you got a
man what are you talking about oh got me
a money man he's going to take care of
me that's what they say right before
they say i lost all my money and i'm on
the cover of sports illustrated broke
you gave it to someone else to manage
and you did not know what you were doing
if you don't do anything else just put
it in the bank at least you know where
it is
do not put money in something you do not
understand ever
unless you understand it and you need us
now
you need to not necessarily go in there
knowledgeable
uh tiffany
a bit more knowledgeable but you need to
leave a bit more knowledgeable
when you sit down with a smart vester
pro
they their their job is to have the
heart of a teacher not the heart of a
salesman or we don't recommend them
click smart investor at daveramsey.com
if you want to find one you said i'm not
in that business but i'm telling you how
to do business with them by the way the
same thing's true with anybody in the
financial world you sit down with an
insurance person they drop their glasses
down the end of their nose act like
you're an idiot fire their butt
some of these insurance people actually
teach intimidation selling as a
technique
to get you to buy without understanding
what you own
you sit down with an attorney and he's
doing your uh
estate plan and you're paying him a
bazillion dollars to do that his job is
to help you understand
not to be
condescending
and i've had to explain it to because
they teach condescension at some law
schools it's one of the courses i think
and i'm just not going listen i'm paying
you 275 an hour for you to look down
your nose hairs at me you can just stop
that crap right now
my net worth 20 times what yours is so
stop it stupid now let's stop and talk
through this again
you're here to advise and teach
not be condescending i don't have any
tolerance for that and you shouldn't
either you deal with a real estate agent
and they roll their eyes because you
don't like the way a house looks you get
the wrong real estate agent
their job is to help you find something
not
intimidate you into buying something
because you're scared of your agent
oh my gosh
but people do it all the time don't they
and so these people in the these
financial realms in particular insurance
mortgage
real estate estate planning
certainly investing
you have to demand that they teach you
they teach you they teach you
because you have to learn
you don't have to get a master's in
business but you have to learn to the
level of sophistication so you don't
lose your money
because it's your fault if you lose your
money not theirs if you give it to
someone and didn't know what it was
going into it's your fault
you were stupid
i've done stupid i know what stupid
looks like
that's how i do this show because i got
a phd in dumb
i'm just trying to tell you don't be
stupid
know what your money's going into or
don't put it in there
good good question this is the dave
ramsey show